oh hello we all know the importance of
airport security but as you head through
the checkpoint this summer travel season
will you know when you're exhibiting
suspicious behaviors that could get you
detained
well we behavior detection officers here
at the TSA are here to help so we've
created this friendly guide to 12
Airport behaviors that might seem normal
to you but to us there are signs of
terrorism we even have a fun behavior
scoring system let's take a look at an
example say you're late normal right
wrong
it shows stress so you run in and your
breathing gets a little bit faster you
appear confused you check the clock a
few times stop bulges in clothing
indicate fear over six points we had to
refer him to law enforcement Oh make no
mistake we will inspect all bulges but
don't sweat it seriously no excessive
perspiration that could lead to sweaty
palms or a strong body odor and again we
can then detain you if you're a French
national this applies to you but how
should you act in the security line you
can't keep your arms directly at your
sides no hand rubbing no padding of your
upper body no repetitive face touch me
that's an exaggerated grooming gesture
now that's a cluster of suicide bomber
behaviors if I've ever seen but where
can you look good arm but don't gaze
down no staring don't appear to look for
security personnel but don't avoid eye
contact with security personnel which
brings us to emotions you know who else
has fun over the summer
Isis no excessive laughter chatter or
Whistler
or excessive yawning gulping throats
clearing or cry and when interacting
with TSA agents don't not do any nothing
you can't ask us security questions but
you also can't ignore us
you can't show unusual interest in us
but you also can't express contempt and
you can't be overly vague but you also
can't be overly specific and above all
do not exhibit a change in your voices
pitch rate or volume oh this could be
based on science it's not but it just
might scare you straight just don't get
scared stiff we here at the TSA would
like to thank you for following these
simple rules much like the terrorists we
can only win if you change your behavior
happy summer travels from all of us in
behavior detection other officialy
terrorists designs include constantly
looking at other travelers wearing a
proper attire for location dry mouth
being distracted pale face for missing
shaving fast I have live great Adam's
apple jump protruding neck arteries
powerful grip of bag having almanacs GPS
unit scuba manuals or loose batteries
and excessive leg shaking head turning
feet shuffling facial flushing fidgeting
trembling or complaints about the
screening process your safety is our
priority
[Music]